This lecture is about document Length
normalization.
In the vector space model.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of the vector
space model.
In particular, we're going to discuss
the issue of document length
normalization.
So far in the lectures about the vector
space model, we have used various
signals from the document to assess the
matching of the document, with
the query.
In particular, we have considered the
term frequency.
The count of the term in the document.
We have also considered its global
statistics.
Such as IDF inverse document frequency.
But we have not considered document length.
So here, I show 2 example documents.
D4 is much shorter with only 100
words.
D6, on the other hand, has 5000
If you look at the matching of these
query words, we see that in D6
there are more matchings of the query
words.
But one might reason that D6
May have matched these query words
In a scattered manner.
So maybe the topic of D6 is not really
about the topic of the query.
So the discussion of campaign at the
beginning of the document may have
nothing to do with the mention of
presidential at the end.
In general, if you think about long
documents, they would have a higher
chance to match any query in fact.
If you generate a long document
randomly by simply sampling words.
From a distribution of words,
Then eventually you probably will match
any query.
So in this sense we should penalize
long documents because they just
naturally have better chances for
matching any query.
And this is the idea of document length
normalization.
We also need to be careful in
avoiding to over penalize long
documents.
On the one hand, we want to penalize
a long document, but on the other hand
we also don't want to over penalize
them.
And the reason is because a document
may be long because of different
reasons.
In one case, the document may be long
because it uses more words.
So for example.
Think about the full text article of a
research paper.
It would use more words than the
corresponding abstract.
So this is the case where we probably
should penalize the matching of.
Long documents such as full paper.
When we compare the matching of words
in such a long document with matching
of the words in a short abstract.
Then long papers generally have higher
chance of matching query words.
Therefore we should penalize them.
However, there is another case when the
document is long and that is when the
document simply has more content.
Now consider another case of a long
document where we simply concatenated
a lot of abstracts of different papers.
In such a case, obviously we don't want
to over penalize such a long document.
Indeed, we probably don't want to
penalize such a document because it's
long.
So that's why we need to be careful
about.
Using the right degree of
penalization.
A method that has been working well
based on research results is called
pivotal length normalization, and in this
case the idea is to use the average document
length as a pivot as a reference
point.
That means we'll assume that for the
average length documents, the score is
about right, so the normalizer would be
1.
But if a document is longer than the
average document length, then there
will be some penalization, whereas if
it's a shorter, then there's even some
reward.
So this is illustrated using this
slide.
On the axis, X-axis, you can see the length
of document.
On the Y axis we show the normalizer in
this case,
the pivoted length normalization formula
for the normalizer is.
is seem to be
Interpolation of 1 and the normalized
document length controlled by a
parameter b here.
So you can see here, when we
first divide the length of the document
by the average document length,
This not only gives us some sense about
how this document is compared with
the average document length, but also
gives us a.
Benefits of not worrying about the unit
of.
Length, we can measure the length by words
or by characters.
Anyway, this Normalizer has an
interesting property.
First we see that if we set the
parameter B to 0 then the value would be
one, so there's no
normalization at all. So b in this sense
controls the length normalization.
Whereas if we set b to a nonzero
value then the normalizer would look
like this so the value would be higher
for documents that are longer than the
average document length.
Whereas the value of the normalizer
would be smaller for
shorter documents.
So in this sense we see there is a
panelization for long documents.
And there is a reward for short
documents.
The degree of penalization is
controlled by b because if we set B to
a larger value than the normalizer
would look like this, there's even more
penalization for long documents and
more reward for the short documents.
By adjusting b which varies from zero
to one, we can control the degree of
Length normalization.
So if we plug in this length normalization
factor into the vector space model
ranking functions that we have already
examined.
Then we will end up having the
following formulas.
And these are in fact the state of
art vector space model formulas.
So let's look at this.
Take a look at each of them.
The first one is called a pivoted
length
Normalization vector space model.
And a reference in the end has details
about derivation of this model and here
we see that it's basically the TF IDF
weighting model that we have discussed.
The idea of component should be very
familiar now to you.
There is also a query term frequency
component.
Here.
And then in the middle, there is the
normalized TF.
And in this case we see we used a
double logarithm.
As we discussed before, and this is to
achieve a sub linear transformation.
But we also put a document length
Normalizer in the bottom.
right, so this would cause
penalization for long document, because
the larger the denominator is
then the smaller TF weighting
is.
And this is of course controlled by the
parameter b here.
And you can see again if b is set to  zero
and there is no length normalization.
OK, so this is one of the two most
effective vector space model formulas.
The next one, called BM25 or okapi.
Is.
Also similar in that it also has a IDF
of component here.
And a query TF component here.
But in the middle, the normalization is
a little bit different.
As we explained there is this.
okapi TF transformation here.
That does sublinear transformation
with the upper bound.
In this case, we have put the length
normalization.
Factor here we are adjusting K, but it
achieves a similar factor, just
because
We put a normalizer in the denominator
therefore.
Again, if a document is longer than the
term weight of this model
So you can see after we have gone
through all the analysis that we talked
about.
And we have.
In the end, reached basically the state
of the art retrieval functions.
So.
So far we have talked about the mainly
how to place the document vector in
the vector space.
And this has played an important role
in determining the effectiveness of the
retrieval function.
But there are also other dimensions
where we did not really examine in detail.
For example, can we further improve the
instantiation of the dimension of the
vector space model?
Now
We've just assumed that the bag of
words representation, so each dimension
is the word.
But obviously we can consider many other
choices.
For example, stemmed words.
Those are the words that are have been
transformed into the same root form.
So that the computation and computing
will all become the same and they can
be matched.
We can do stop word removal.
This is to remove
Some very common words that don't carry
any content like "the", "a" or "of".
We can use phrases to define
dimensions.
We can even use latent semantic
analysis to find some clusters of words
that represent a latent concept as one
dimension.
We can also use smaller units, like a
character N-grams.
Those are sequences of N characters for
dimensions.
However, in practice, people have found
that the bag of words representation
with phrases is still the most
effective one, and it's also efficient.
So this is still so far the most
popular dimension instantiation method.
And it's used in all the major search
engines.
I should also mention that sometimes we
need to do language-specific and
domain-specific tokenization, and this
is actually very important as we might
have variations of terms.
That might prevent us from matching
them with each other, even though they
mean the same thing in some languages
like Chinese
There is also the challenge in
segmenting
Text to obtain word boundaries because
it's just a sequence of characters.
a word might correspond to 1 character
or two characters or even 3 characters.
So it's
Easier in English when we have a space
to separate the words, but in some
other languages we may need to do some
natural language processing to figure
out where all the boundaries for words.
There is also a possibility to improve
the similarity function, and so far we
have used the dot product, but one can
imagine there are other measures.
For example, we can measure the cosine
of the angle between two vectors, or we
can use Euclidean distance measure.
And these are all possible.
But dot product seems still the best
and one reason is because it's very
general.
In fact, it's sufficiently general.
If you consider the possibilities of
doing weighting in different ways.
So for example, cosine measure can be
regarded as the dot product of two
normalized vectors.
That means we first normalize each
vector and then we take the dot product
that would be equivalent to the cosine
measure.
I just mentioned that the BM 25 seems
to be one of the most effective
formulas.
But there has been also further
development in improving BM.
25, Although none of these works have
changed the BM25 fundamentally.
So in one line work people have derived
BM25F.
Here F stands for Field and this is to
use BM25 for documents with the
structures.
So for example you might consider Title
Field, the abstract or body or the
research article or even anchor text.
On the web pages, those are the text
fields that describe links to other
pages, and these can all be combined
with appropriate weights of different
fields to help improve scoring for a
document.
When we use BM25 for such a document.
And the obvious choice is to apply the
BM25 for each field and then combine
the scores.
Basically the idea of BM25F is to first
combine the frequency counts of terms
in all the fields.
And then apply BM 25.
Now this has advantage of avoiding over
counting the first occurrence of the
term.
Remember, in the sub linear
transformation of TF, the first
occurrence is very important and it
contributes a large weight and if we do
that for all the fields than the same
term might have gained a lot of
advantage in every field.
But when we combine these word
frequencies together, we just do the
transformation.
A one time at that time, then the extra
occurrences will not be counted as
fresh first occurrences.
And this method has been working very
well for scoring structure documents.
The other line of extension is called a
PM 25 plus.
In this line, researchers have
addressed the problem of over
penalization of long documents by BM 25.
So to address this problem, the fix is
actually quite simple.
We can simply add a small constant to
the TF normalization formula, But
what's interesting is that we can
analytically prove that by doing such a
small modification.
We will fix the problem of over
penalization of long documents by the
original BM25 so the new formula,
called BM25+.
Is empirically an analytically shown to
be better than BM25.
So to summarize, all what we have said
about the vector space model.
Here are the major takeaway points.
First, in such a model we use the
similarity notion relevance, assuming
that the relevance of a document with
respect to a query is.
Basically proportional to the
similarity between the query and
document, so naturally that implies
that the query an document must be
represented in the same way, and in
this case we represent them as vectors
in high dimensional vector space where
the dimensions are defined by words or
concepts or terms in general.
And we generally need to use a lot of
heuristics to design the ranking
function.
We use.
Some examples to show the need for
several heuristics, including TF
weighting and transformation.
and IDF weighting and document
length normalization.
These major heuristics are the most
important heuristics to ensure such a
general ranking function to work well
for all kinds of text.
And finally, BM25 and pivoted
normalization seems to be the most
effective formulas out of the vector
space model.
Now I have to say that I've put BM 25
in the category of vector space model.
But in fact the BM 25 has been derived
using probabilistic modeling.
So the reason why I've put it in the
vector space model is.
First, the ranking function actually
has a nice interpretation in the vector
space model, we can easily see it
looks very much like a vector space
model with a special weighting
function.
The second reason is because the
original BM25 has somewhat different
form of IDF.
And that form of IDF actually doesn't
really work so well
as the standard IDF.
That you have seen here, so as
effective retrieval function BM25
should probably use a heuristic
modification of the IDF to make it
even more look like a vector space
model.
There are some additional readings.
The first is a paper about the pivoted
length normalization.
It's an excellent example of using
empirical data analysis to suggest the
need for length normalization and then
further derived length normalization
formula.
The second is the original paper where
BM25 was proposed.
The 3rd paper has a thorough discussion
of BM25 and its extensions.
Particularly BM25F.
And finally, the last paper has a
discussion of improving BM25 to
correct the over penalization of long
documents.